[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend wenn laut Friedrich
Merz die CDU die Alternative für
Deutschland mit Substanz ist ist dann
das Original die Alternative ohne
Substanz wie auch immer die AFD ist
definitiv nicht ohne Wähler jedenfalls
liegen sie in den Umfragen auf Platz
zwei mit bis zu 20% zudem gab es
kommunale Wahlerfolge in Thüringen und
Sachsen-Anhalt in dieser
höhenflugstimmung ist die AFD nun zum
Parteitag in Magdeburg zusammengekommen
und über die koalitionsfähigkeit seiner
Partei habe ich vor zwei Stunden mit
ko-chef Tino krupala gesprochen zunächst
aber Andreas Weise mit seinem Bericht
über die Zusammenkunft der delegieren
die AFD in Jubiläums und Feierstimmung
auf ihrem Bundesparteitag in Magdeburg
zehn Jahre nach ihrer Gründung sind die
Umfragewerte der Partei bundesweit so
hoch wie nie ist es eigene Programmatik
Fehler oder Unvermögen der anderen
Parteien manche Delegierte ist unsicher
ob der Trend anhält
die Bundestagswahl ist ja glaube ich 25
erst also das wird natürlich schon
relativ schwer das hohe Niveau dann auch
zu halten
kommt immer darauf an was sie übrigens
ein Parteien denn alles Richtig oder
Falsch machen ne und im Moment machen
sie ziemlich viel falsch in der Partei
Spitze freut man sich vor allem über die
brandmauer-debatte in der CDU
unverhoffter Rückenwind so sieht es die
parteiko-sprecherin
ich habe mich vor allen Dingen recht
gewundert also das hätte ich so nicht
gedacht
in der CDU so eine Unsicherheit und
Nervosität herrscht das ist ja auch eben
Ausfluss aus der Partei dass dort auch
darüber gesprochen wird und das ganze
natürlich auch nicht unkritisch gesehen
wird die Strategie der AFD erst den
Osten dann die ganze Republik gefragt ob
Partner für Erinnerungsfotos in
Magdeburg Robert Sesselmann erster AFD
Landrat in thüringischen Sonneberg nicht
der einzige Wahlerfolg der Partei in
letzter Zeit
vor wenigen Wochen gelang es uns hier in
Sachsen-Anhalt mit Hannes lot den ersten
Bürgermeister für unsere Partei zu
gewinnen und wir haben damit den
Staffelstab den Robert Sesselmann in
Thüringen aufgenommen hat ebenfalls
würdevoll übernommen Ende September
rechnen sein Landesverband und er sich
gute Chancen aus in Bitterfeld-Wolfen
zum ersten Mal einen Oberbürgermeister
Posten zu erringen
vor dem Veranstaltungsgelände Proteste
selbst am Himmel über Magdeburg Taten
Gegner der Partei ihre Meinung kund im
Saal scharfe Rhetorik gegen die Grünen
Relativierung von Russlands
Angriffskrieg und die Forderung nach dem
EU-Austritt das Teile der AFD durch den
Verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestuft werden politisch motiviert so
die einhellige Meinung hier das Alice
Weidel jetzt doch deutlich die Nähe zu
Partei Rechtsaußen Björn höcke sucht der
erst morgen nach Magdeburg kommt ein
Signal dafür wie sehr die Partei sich in
ihren zehn Jahren gehäutet und
radikalisiert hat und doch redet die
co-sprecherin von Kanzlerkandidaten
signalisiert gar Kompromissbereitschaft
in Richtung CDU im Bund sieht
Gemeinsamkeiten unser Programm hat
natürlich große Schnittmengen mit einer
CDU vor drei Jahrzehnten so und ich
glaube da lässt sich in sehr gutes Paket
herausschneiden fragt sich nur ob die
Wähler noch so denken wie vor 30 Jahren
und vielleicht noch eine ganz
interessante Zahl 43% der Bürger und
Bürgerinnen finden die demokratischen
Parteien sollten eine Zusammenarbeit mit
der AFD generell ausschließen und genau
das tun die Parteien ja auch unter
anderem weil die AFD in deren Augen
verfassungsfeindlich und
antidemokratisch ist das dürfte Tino
propala als afd-chef anders sehen und
damit erst einmal einen schönen guten
Abend nach Magdeburg oder der
Bundesparteitag stattfindet
schönen guten Abend Frau Hayali Herr
grupala wie wollen Sie denn trotz der
gerade von mir genannten Fakten es
schaffen andere Parteien von sich zu
überzeugen
sie haben jetzt Umfragen hier
angesprochen und keine Fakten von daher
gibt es auch andere Umfragen die das
natürlich auch zum Beispiel gerade auf
kommunaler aber auf Landesebene
wesentlich anders sehen von daher wird
sich die Politik und werden sich auch
die anderen Parteien gerade was unsere
Umfragen aber auch wenn Sie unsere
Wahlergebnisse angeht die nächsten
Monate und auch vielleicht die nächsten
zwei Jahre anders entscheiden müssen
weil es ohne die AFD keine anderen
Mehrheiten mehr geben wird ohne die AFD
sozusagen ein regieren nicht mehr
möglich ist und da ich denke das ist
unsere Aufgabe auch in Zukunft daran zu
arbeiten und im Endeffekt müssen das die
anderen Parteien auch ihren Wählern
erklären warum sie im Prinzip eine
legitimierte Partei eine demokratische
Partei dann ausschließen wollen weil der
wählerwelle missachtet wird sie haben in
letzter Zeit immer wieder mal so ein
framing dann benutzt dass sie nämlich
sagen wir bzw das Verhalten der anderen
Parteien sein
antidemokratisch weil sie eben nicht mit
ihnen zusammenarbeiten wollen und ist es
nun mal so dass man natürlich mit ihnen
nicht zusammenarbeiten muss es geht ja
um Mehrheiten und sie haben jetzt gerade
gesagt klar sie sind eine demokratisch
gewählte Partei wie sie es mit der
Demokratie wiederum halten daran
bestehen Zweifel der Verfassungsschutz
hat sie als rechtsextremer
extremistischer Verdachtsfall eingestuft
und solange sie doch das Problem nicht
lösen wird doch niemand mit ihnen
kooperieren wollen
wenn ich jetzt nicht nur in die Umfragen
sie auch in den letzten Wahlergebnisse
dann sieht man doch wieder Wähler im
Prinzip in und der ist der das ist das
souverän was in Deutschland entscheidet
nicht der Verfassungsschutz entscheidet
wie die AFD hier in Zukunft Politik
betreibt auch wenn das natürlich gerne
versucht wenn man die Aussagen die
undemokratischen Aussagen zum Beispiel
von einer halben Bank sieht wie er die
AFD klein halten möchte und dazu
Unterstützung brauchen also hier geht's
noch nicht im Rechtsextremismus mehr
hier sieht man ganz klar dass die der
AFD diskreditiert werden soll als
Opposition oder wenn der thüringische
Verfassungsschutzpräsident Kramer die
Wähler der AFD diffamiert und kritisiert
als braunen Bodensatz was hat das mit
Demokratie zu tun wissen sie diejenigen
die den Tag hinein von Demokratie
sprechen das sind diejenigen die
wirklich die die Demokratie verächtlich
machen und wenn ich sehe dass wir auch
im Bundestag aber auch im
Landesparlamenten demokratische Rechte
nicht bekommen indem wir
ausschussvorsitzen nicht besetzen können
im Bundestag Vizepräsident nicht
besetzen können hier zeigt sich wer
wirklich demokratisch ist aber das sind
natürlich auch die Mittel der Demokratie
die da benutzt werden ob die dann immer
gut sind ist dann vielleicht eine andere
Frage dass sie Probleme mit dem
Verfassungsschutz haben das ist ja
bekannt wo aber und Alice Weidel hat
schon auch gesagt klar wir müssen dann
Kompromisse eingehen wo sie ist denn
diese Kompromisslinie doch in der NATO
bleiben doch den Euro behalten doch
höcke den man Faschisten nennen darf
rauswerfen doch weniger ethnisch
kulturelle Homogenität also wo genau
wollen Sie Kompromisse machen
das sind alles Themen über die man sich
dann unterhalten muss wenn man die
Ergebnisse eingefahren hat und wenn man
in Gespräche auch kommt natürlich sind
wir und werden wir dann kompromissbereit
sein aber ich sage es auch ganz deutlich
nicht um jeden Preis wir sind die
Alternative für Deutschland wir wollen
alternative Politik machen wir wollen
uns hauptsächlich für die Interessen der
Bürger einsetzen für die Interessen der
Industrie für den Mittelstand was in
diesem Land keine andere Parteien mehr
macht wenn ich z.B sehe dass wir in der
Rezeption fahren dass wir hohe
Energiepreise haben
eine Kompromisslinie bei den genannten
Themen
wissen Sie ich mache jetzt keine
konkreten Themen auf weil ich das in
dieser Position erstmal überhaupt nicht
muss das macht man dann wenn man auf
diese Ergebnisse eingefahren hat und
wenn man sich z.B
über die Situation wird niemand mit
Ihnen zusammenarbeiten wollen
wissen Sie Frau herrali ich muss nicht
andere Parteien überzeugen wir müssen
und das tun wir den Wähler überzeugen
den Bürger das ist das souverän und der
Bürger bestimmt die Politik nicht die
Partei an sich und wir müssen auch nicht
was sie immer wieder höre Politik
erklären wissen Sie wer Politik erklären
muss der hat schon ein Problem wir sind
die Interessenvertreter ich bin der
Interessenvertreter einer Partei ich bin
souverän und auch demokratisch gewählt
worden ich vertrete einen Wahlkreis ich
vertrete die Interessen der Bürger und
das wollen die Bürger auch von der
Politik sehen und dann wird man auch zu
Kompromissen kommen Björn höcke den ich
gerade schon angesprochen habe der zum
ja offiziell aufgelösten Flügel gehört
also zur völkisch nationalistischen
Gruppe hat sehr viel Einfluss und Macht
in ihrer Partei mehr noch er gilt es im
Grunde so als Strippenzieher eventuell
mit einem Grund warum ihre
co-vorsitzenende Alice Weide Herrn höcke
umarmt wenn ich da um Garant sie will ja
angeblich Kanzlerkandidatin werden gehen
sie damit
Fraktionsvorsitzende wie der und wir
reden natürlich mit allen Mitgliedern
unserer Partei und das ist auch unsere
Aufgabe helgemacht Gunter gute Arbeit in
Thüringen und das ist auch seinen Platz
aktuell und von daher denke ich mal über
die Kanzlerkandidatur müssen wir nicht
in diesem Jahr und auch nicht im Anfang
des nächsten Jahres reden das werden wir
dann tun wenn die Zeit reif ist ich
denke es ist wichtig und wir werden dann
kannst du Kandidaten stellen weil wir
natürlich auch Verantwortung übernehmen
wollen und die Bürger auch von uns
Verantwortung erwarten das sagen die
Umfragen das sagen die ersten Ergebnisse
und darauf stellen wir uns auch ein mit
wem auch immer denn Mehrheiten werden
sie alleine sicherlich nicht erreichen
am Wochenende Herr propalla geht es bei
ihnen auch um Europa in ihrem leidantrag
für die Europawahl an dem sie
mitgeschrieben haben stand ja zunächst
das wissen sie geordnete Auflösung der
EU jetzt sind sie zurückgerudert die
Formulierung war ein
redaktionelles Versehen wenn es jetzt
nach ihnen ginge ganz kurz EU auflösen
oder nicht
ja wir haben immer gesagt wenn es eine
Reformation dieser EU nicht möglich ist
und wenn wir uns einfach mal die
Erfolgsgeschichte ich sage das wirklich
in Anführungszeichen dieser EU angucken
schauen wir uns die maastrichtverträge
ein was ist eigentlich mit denen die
überhaupt noch jemand ein was ist mit
Dublin eins und zwei was Migration in
Europa angeht was ist mit frontext alles
Dinge wo die EU Verträge gebrochen haben
die niemand mehr interessieren von daher
von daher sagen wir es muss die
Möglichkeit hier Mitgliedstaaten geben
wie z.B auch Großbritannien getan hat
diese EU auch zu verlassen naja sie
können tatsächlich wenn sie denn
regieren würden rausgehen aber sie
können Sie natürlich als Einzelstaat
nicht auflösen so weit geht es dann doch
nicht telepropeller vielen Dank für das
Gespräch heute und übrigens 87% der
Deutschen wollen nicht dass Deutschland
die EU verlässt das nur noch mal
nebenbei alles Gute für Sie
vielen Dank
was führt bei Menschen zu Verdruss wenn
es im politischen Streit nicht um die
Sache sondern eher um Egos geht wenn
wichtige Themen scheinbar vergessen wenn
Nöte Fragen und Bedürfnisse der Menschen
ignoriert werden oder aber auch wenn
wichtige infrastrukturelle Dinge die
gerade in den kleineren Regionen
relevant sind nicht ernst genommen
werden ein vielleicht auf den ersten
Blick profanes für die Menschen im
ländlichen Raum übrigens egal ob in
nord-süd-ost oder West großes Problem
ist die Frage wenn um mich herum alles
wegbricht von der Kita über den
Supermarkt bis hin zum Busverkehr passt
dann diese Fragen stellen sich gerade
gut 1.000 Einwohner in Sachsen mit dem
letzten Lebensmittelladen stirbt der
Konsum im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
wir sind in Kohren-Sahlis halbe Strecke
zwischen Leipzig und Chemnitz sächsische
Provinz hier passiert gerade
exemplarisch etwas was auch an vielen
anderen Orten Deutschlands geschieht das
öffentliche Leben stirbt einen langsamen
Tod das Symbol dafür ist in
Kohren-Sahlis der Konsum an diesem
Wochenende wird der Lebensmittelladen
für immer schließen nach vier
Jahrzehnten es ist traurig für all die
alten Leute es gibt hier keine
ausreichende Busverbindung wo sollen die
hin es hat nicht jeder Familie im Ort
eigentlich auf gut deutsch
der Konsum ostdeutsches
Identifikationssymbol und in der 1300
Einwohner Stadt die letzte Möglichkeit
Lebensmittel zu kaufen die
Mitarbeiterinnen wurden vor sechs Wochen
vor vollendete Tatsachen gestellt vor
der Kamera wollen sie ihre Tränen nicht
zeigen also man kommt jeden Tag mit
gemischten Gefühlen herein wenn man die
Kundschaft zum letzten Mal sieht
der Arbeitskollegen der Rest der übrig
geblieben ist es ganz hart
einst war korin sales eine blühende
Stadt bekannt für seine vielen
Töpfereien ein Touristenmagnet dann
zogen nach der Wende viele junge Weg die
Gasthäuser wurden geschlossen die
Apotheke aufgegeben die Sparkasse
abgezogen und nun der Konsum ein
Dominoeffekt
steht ja für einen generelles Problem
mit unserer Gesellschaft wenn es
politisch nicht geschafft wird die
Flucht vom Land wie Wanderung vom Land
in die Stadt zu stoppen oder sogar
umzukehren dann wird das was in
kohrensales passiert ist in den nächsten
20 Jahren in vielen Orten passieren in
der sächsischen Kleinstadt ist die
Unruhe groß viele wissen im Moment nicht
wie sie demnächst an Lebensmittel kommen
sollen der nächste Supermarkt ist 8 km
entfernt
irgendwann ist das auch alle und was
machen sie dann
der Bürgermeister im dauerkrisenmodus
Carsten Richter sucht nun einen neuen
lebensmittellieferer will
Dienstleistungen ansiedeln
touristenherlocken Angebote schaffen
gegen die Lehre im nächsten Jahr sind
Kommunalwahlen und schon oft genug gab
es die Quittung für Unzufriedenheit per
Wahlzettel
hat das ja schon in den vergangenen
Kommunalwahlen auch gesehen dass eben
wirklich auch das muss man sagen schön
die AFD auch in Größenordnung Zugewinne
hatte wir müssen uns auf unsere Aufgaben
konzentrieren und ich sehe hier schon
dass viele viele Leute da sind die noch
mitwirken wollen die Politik hat große
Aufgaben vor allem im ländlichen Raum
damit auch die nächste Generation hier
noch eine Zukunft hat
und wir schauen nun auf den russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine nicht
alles lässt sich sicher verifizieren
aber das was mehrere Quellen melden das
hast du jetzt in den Nachrichten Gundula
die Ukraine spricht von Erfolgen in der
Gegenoffensive zur Befreiung ihrer
Gebiete so soll ein kleines aber
strategisch wichtiges Dorf zurückerobert
worden sein das ukrainische Militär
veröffentlicht Aufnahmen die den
Vormarsch zeigen sollen zugleich
Beschuldigten Moskau Kiew eine
terror-attacke gegen die russische Stadt
targan Rock die russische
Luftverteidigung habe eine ukrainische
Rakete abgefangen hier weiß den
russischen Vorwurf zurück
beim Russland Afrika Gipfel hat Kreml
Chef Putin zugesagt den
Friedensvorschlag afrikanischer
Staatschefs für die Ukraine zu prüfen
zugleich wie es er Vorbedingungen wie
einen russischen Truppenabzug erneut
zurück außerdem kündigte Putin erneut
höre Getreideexporte nach Afrika an die
wenigen anwesenden afrikanischen
Staatschefs forderten dagegen die
Wiederaufnahme des getreideabkommens
der mutmaßlich Verantwortliche für den
Putsch im Niger hat sich zum neuen
Machthaber ernannt der Chef der
Präsidenten Garde general Gianni
erklärte sich in einer Fernsehansprache
zum Präsidenten des nationalen Rates der
entmachtete demokratisch gewählte
Präsident bazoom ist nach UN-Angaben in
seinem Haus festgesetzt die EU drohte
den neuen Machthabern mit dem Stopp von
Hilfszahlungen
Japan fährt einen 48 Jahre alten
Atomreaktor wieder hoch der Reaktorblock
Nummer eins des Kernkraftwerks Taka hama
ist damit der älteste operierende
Kernreaktor Japans er war nach der
Atomkatastrophe von Fukushima 2011 nicht
mehr in Betrieb genommen worden bis
jetzt trotz der ständigen Gefahren neuer
Erdbeben setzt Japan weiter auf
Atomstrom
der brennende Auto fragte in der Nordsee
hat deutlich mehr Elektroautos an
Bordells bisher angenommen laut Reederei
nicht 25 sondern fast 500 erstmals
konnten Spezialisten an Bord die Bergung
wird durch die schwer zu löschenden
Batterien der Fahrzeuge erschwert die
Küstenwache teilte mit der Brand habe
inzwischen nachgelassen die Gefahr einer
Umweltkatastrophe sei aber nicht gebannt
von einer schiffsbergung zur nächsten
die allerdings findet nicht ganz so viel
Beachtung denn sie findet weit weg statt
konkret vor der Westküste des Jemen der
47 Jahre alte Tanker FSO sofair liegt
dort seit Ende der 80er Jahre und wurde
als schwimmendes Lager und
entladeterminal für Öl genutzt seit
Beginn des Bürgerkriegs zwischen
Regierungstruppen und tut die Rebellen
im Jahr 2015 wurde er nicht mehr
gewartet und könnte laut Experten
jederzeit zerbrechen explodieren oder
Feuer fangen mit 200 Millionen Liter Öl
an Bord die müssen nun abgepumpt werden
auf ein anderes Schiff organisiert haben
dass die Vereinten Nationen die Bergung
wird auch von ihr bezahlt wem das Öl
aber hinterher gehört den Hoodie
Rebellen oder der international
anerkannten Regierung das ist völlig
unklar über die tickende Zeitbombe
Kolonie
acht Jahre Bürgerkrieg und acht Jahre
eine drohende Gefahr die immer lauerte
die Fischer im Hafen von hordeder
fürchteten stets ihr Auskommen zu
verlieren und ihre Existenz weil da
draußen auf dem Meer ein vor sich
hinrotten der Tanke liegt voller Öl der
Krieg verhinderte seine Bergung
ein Ölleck würde die Fischarten hier
vernichten und die Korallenriffe
zerstören nicht nur hier bei uns
es würde keine Arbeit mehr geben für uns
alle Fische wären tot von was würden wir
da noch leben
nicht nur das eine Ölkatastrophe auf dem
Meer würde das Ende der Anlieferung von
humanitärer Hilfe bedeuten auf die
Millionen jiminiten angewiesen sind
wenige Kilometer vor der Küste geht es
um nichts weniger als die Rettung des
Roten Meeres das Abpumpen von rund 200
Millionen Liter jemenitischem Öl von der
FSO auf einen anderen Tanker die
Ingenieure arbeiten unterstehte
explosionsgefahr
die Schafe könnte jederzeit
auseinanderbrechen Rohre sind marode
Salzwasser drang in den Maschinenraum
der Rost nackt am Schiff
wir müssen konstant zum Beispiel die
Luftqualität in den Tanks auf beiden
Seiten messen um die Explosionsgefahr zu
reduzieren aber es können auch einfach
technische Mangel entstehen die Sache
ist 47 Jahre alt Ventile können brechen
der super-tanker liegt nicht weit
entfernt von geschützten Inselketten
bekannt für ihre Artenvielfalt ein
Ölteppich würde Mangroven und
korallengefährten und die
Meerwasserentsalzung für fast 2
Millionen Menschen eine der wichtigsten
Routen der Weltwirtschaft wäre
unterbrochen
zwei Jahre mühsamer Verhandlungen mit
den jemenitischen Kriegsparteien
brauchte es und einen brüchigen
Waffenstillstand ist diese
Rettungsaktion der Vereinten Nationen
beginnen konnte
Regierungen und Schulklassen spendeten
aber für die Entsorgung des Tankers
brauchen die UN noch 21 Millionen Dollar
in meiner Appell auch weiterhin bleibt
andere Regierung aber auch an
Unternehmen und ich sage immer wieder
vor allem die
Öl-Industrie das sind Sektoren für die
wir hier auch letztlich tätig sind denn
das sind ihre Weltmärkte das in ihre
Schifffahrtsrouten das sind ihre
Einkommensmöglichkeiten
klappt die Bergung wollen die UN mit den
Kriegsparteien klären wie das auf einem
neuen Tanker gesicherte Öl dem Jemen zu
Gute kommen soll
damit wieder zurück nach Deutschland im
vergangenen Jahr sollen hier bei uns
mehr als 8000 Menschen an den Folgen der
Hitze gestorben sein das soll sich jetzt
mit Plan ändern Gundula
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach will die
Zahl der Hitze Toten halbieren und hat
dazu einen hitzeschutzplan vorgestellt
gemeinsam mit Ärzten
pflegevertreterinnen und weiteren
Experten wurden Maßnahmen vereinbart so
soll künftig bei extremer Hitze auch per
SMS zu Schutzmaßnahmen aufgefordert
werden wie viel trinken Schatten suchen
körperliche Anstrengungen vermeiden
die Inflation in Deutschland hat etwas
nachgelassen im Juli kletterten die
Preise im Vorjahresvergleich um
6,2% nach noch 6,4% im Juni
überdurchschnittlich stark um 11%
steigen nach wie vor die Preise für
Nahrungsmittel die hohe Inflation
belastet Verbraucher und Unternehmen
dazu leidet die Industrie unter der
weltweiten Konjunkturschwäche im
Ergebnis stagnierte die deutsche
Wirtschaft im zweiten Quartal Valerie
Halle immer wieder warnen Ökonomen vor
einer Rezession wie wahrscheinlich ist
das also
ja wenn man den Prognosen glauben mag
dann wird die deutsche Wirtschaft schon
im dritten Quartal wieder schrumpfen
eine Sorge ist die Industrie lange war
sie eine Stütze jetzt aber Lehren sich
die Auftragsbücher vor allem die
Nachfrage aus Übersee lässt nach und das
natürlich gar nicht gut für die
exportorientierte deutsche Wirtschaft
auch die gestiegenen Zinsen bremsen die
Konjunktur des verteuert Investitionen
und außerdem zieht der Bau die
Konjunktur runter der Internationale
Währungsfonds geht aktuell davon aus
dass Deutschland als einziges großes
Industrieland in einer Rezession rutscht
immerhin der Arbeitsmarkt ist nach wie
vor weitgehend robust die Märkte
schauten heute auch auf die europäische
Banken auf sich und deren Erkenntnisse
eines Stresstests wie stehen denn da die
deutschen Geldhäuser da
vergleichsweise eher schlecht einige
belegen die hinteren Plätze die DZ Bank
die Hela war und die Nord lbzellen zu
den fünf Schwächsten in stituten
europaweit was bedeutet dass Ihre
Kapitalpolster im Ernstfall deutlich
schrumpfen würden heißt aber wiederum
nicht dass sie nicht gewappnet wären und
das gilt für Europas Banken insgesamt
denen bescheinigen die Aufseher der EZB
dass sie krisenfest sind der Test war
diesmal übrigens härter und ist dennoch
besser ausgefallen als vor zwei Jahren
was ja auch für die Robustheit von
europäischen Banken spricht Valerie
Halle vielen Dank
zum Sport und da zunächst zum
Tennisturnier in Hamburg Alexander
Zverev hat mit einem klaren Sieg gegen
den Franzosen von Asche das Halbfinale
erreicht während Daniel Altmaier im
Viertelfinale an dem Chinesen junjing
gescheitert ist
sensationell weiter dagegen ist die
deutsche Debütantin nomanoa
Wildcard ins Turnier kam und morgen im
Finale steht gegen
aranzarousse aus den Niederlanden
bei der Fußball WM der Frauen in
Australien und Neuseeland geht es um den
Einzug ins Achtelfinale England und
China sichern sich durch 1:0 Siege ihre
Chancen und selbst die Verliererinnen
aus Dänemark und Haiti sind weiter im
Rennen enttäuscht sind die Spielerinnen
aus Argentinien und Südafrika die sich
Unentschieden trennten
was konnte dieser Mann eigentlich nicht
seine vielseitige und oftmals auch
umstrittene Arbeit umfasst der Romane
Novellen Theaterstücke Hörspiele
Übersetzungen Aufsätze reden Vorlesungen
er hat also das ganze Feld bearbeitet
von Sprachkunst bis hin zu Spracharbeit
Martin weiser hat Geschichte erlebt und
mit seinem Dasein Geschichte geschrieben
nun ist er im Alter von 96 Jahren
gestorben Claudio Armbruster mit einem
Nachruf auf einen der bedeutendsten und
streitbarsten Autoren der deutschen
Nachkriegsliteratur
in dir herum so fühlte sich an aber den
Tod gibt es nicht so wenig wie das Leben
nur Wörter an die wir uns halten können
in all der Leere
das ist
doch das Gute der Schriftstellerei die
Wörter
die Wörter und die Worte waren sein
Schwert und seine Liebe ein Leben lang
ich darf nun gleich mit einer
Kinderfrage beginnen warum schreiben sie
da kann ich fast eine Kinder Antwort
drauf geben weil sich herausgestellt hat
dass dabei die Zeit am schnellsten
vergeht ich muss Geld verdienen ich kann
nichts dagegen tun
dass ich in mir andauernd Sätze bilden
Martin Walser gestorben und geboren am
Bodensee vier Töchter hat er und einen
Sohn und ein sehr bewegtes Leben er
begann als Rundfunk Redakteur dann
Finger an zu schreiben seinen ersten
Roman ihn in Philippsburg da war er 30
was in Erinnerung bleibt neben seinen
Büchern der politisierer der sich
einmischte der provozierte und sich
provozieren ließ der schwankte zwischen
ganz links und ganz rechts
einer der größten Skandale der
Bundesrepublik weil das Dankesrede zum
Friedenspreis des Deutschen Buchhandels
in der Paulskirche 1998
einsetzbares einschüchterungsmittel oder
Moralkeule oder auch nur Pflichtübung
geistige Brandstiftung warf in der
Zentralrat der Juden vor viel später
erst bezeichnete Walser die Rede als
seinen schlimmsten Fehler
und dann kam Herr Bubis und habe mir
angeboten sozusagen eine Art Versöhnung
er hat einen Vorwurf zurücknehmen wollen
und da war ich so verkrampft dass ich
das habe nicht akzeptieren können und
das tut mir nachträglich sehr sehr
leicht und sein größtes Trauma bleibt im
Gedächtnis der Verriss seines Romans
jenseits der Liebe
jenseits der Literatur urteilte Marcel
reich ranitzki
er kann Romane
kurz nach dieser Kritik schrieb Walser
ein fliehendes Pferd seinen größten
Erfolg und danach immer weiter fast
jedes Jahr ein Buch das sogenannte Leben
ist schon ein Roman
du muss man sich nicht
aufzuschreiben
[Musik]
Martin Walser hat ihn aufgeschrieben
unermüdlich seinen Lebensroman jetzt ist
er zu Ende
[Musik]
wer mehr sagt als er tut Predigt wer
weniger sagt als er tut lügt wer sagt
was er tut ist eitel und wer tut was er
sagt ist gut in diesem Sinne das sagt
Martin Walser direkt im Anschluss an das
heute Journal hat das ZDF eine
ausführliche Würdigung Martin weises ins
Programm genommen dann sage ich machen
sie es gut wo auch immer Sie sind und
bis morgen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend auch wenn bei uns der
Sommer im Moment eher kühl und
regnerisch daherkommt so sieht es
weltweit gesehen doch ganz anders aus da
folgt eine Rekordmeldung der nächsten
Hitze an Land und beunruhigender Weise
auch in den weltenmeeren und jetzt hat
die Weltorganisation für Meteorologie
gestern erklärt dass der Juli 2023 der
heißeste jemals gemessene Monat weltweit
sein wird und das mit einem solchen
Abstand wir sehen hier den orangenen
Temperaturverlauf für das Jahr 2023 im
Vergleich zu den temperaturverläufen der
vorherigen Jahre in grau und da ist der
Abstand im Juli so groß dass das jetzt
schon klar ist obwohl der Monat noch gar
nicht zu Ende ist und in einem neuen
wärmeren Klima wird das auch so
weitergehen daran sehen wir wie
notwendig unsere klimaanstrengungen sind
wir kommen jetzt zum Wetter bei uns
heute Nacht da kühlt es ab auf nur 17
bis 13 Grad weil es auch meistens
bewölkt ist die Schauer und Gewitter im
Süden die ziehen dann langsam nach Osten
ab aber bis zu morgen gibt es schon neue
Schauer und Gewitter im Westen und
Südwesten des Landes und die kommen
morgen dann bis in den Osten des Landes
voran es kommt aber immer wieder etwas
nach sodass vor allem am Nachmittag dann
auch in der Mitte und im Süden Lokal
Unwetter mit dabei sein können mit
Starkregen und Sturmböen der Wind ist
frisch aus westlichen Richtungen die
Sonne sehen wir häufig nur zwischendurch
dazu gibt es Temperaturen zwischen 20
und immerhin 26 Grad der Sonntag wird
etwas ruhiger mit etwas mehr Sonne aber
schon am Montag geht der Juli wieder
richtig nass zu Ende und es wird auch
wieder etwas kühler tschüss